alienta a warm y car y la china cansa
kim al suyo causa su patronato
buenas noches mujeres hombres enseñar es
dejar una huella en la vida de alguien
hay una dinámica que en lo personal me
gusta mucho nos ayuda a romper el hielo
y romper tensiones cuando afrontas a
grupos nuevos
la dinámica se llama las frutas en la
canasta se trata de formar un círculo y
cada integrante tiene que escoger una
fruta y decirle en voz alta
entonces el narrador de la historia va a
contar una narración sobre qué va a
comprar frutas y cada vez que mencioné
una fruta la persona que escogió se debe
levantar e ir caminando atrás del que
dirige la dinámica en cierta parte de la
historia el que dirige va a decir se
cayó la canasta entonces todos los que
están atrás caminando tienen que escoger
un puesto diferente al que tenían
inicialmente pero alguien se va a quedar
levantado porque la persona que narra va
a tomar el asiento de alguien
esta persona que se queda levantada
contará su historia y así se repite esta
dinámica unas dos o tres veces para
poder reírnos y aflojar nos un poquito
la historia dice más o menos así fui al
mercado porque quería ensalada de frutas
entonces escogí mandarinas y el mandarín
a la persona que escogió la mandarina se
levanta y empieza a caminar atrás mío en
este caso compre naranjas melones
toronjas también manzanas etcétera
estaba tan pesada mi canasta que justo
al salir del mercado en una grada me
tropecé y se cayó la canasta entonces
todos corren por sus vidas por buscar un
asiento y yo me siento rápido así que
una persona se queda de pie y empieza a
narrar su historia
hace casi 7 años llegué a la provincia
del napo a la ciudad del tena y hace
algunos años empecé a trabajar con un
grupo que lo primero que encontré fue un
montón de frutas caídas
nadie se había preocupado en levantarlas
ni siquiera escuchar sus historias los
chicos y chicas con las que yo trabajo
asisten a un colegio público en la
jornada nocturna muchos enfrentan
riesgos psicosociales y para que tengan
un panorama claro de lo que les quiero
explicar muchos son padres y madres
siendo muy jovencitos viven abandonados
porque sus papás viven en las riberas en
las comunidades aledañas así que les
visitan tal vez una vez al mes les
hurten de víveres y en este cuarto viven
cuatro o cinco adolescentes que son
obligados a trabajar por la pobreza que
enfrentan entonces durante la mañana
trabajan y llegan a la noche con la
intención de aprender
ante esta realidad
cómo podemos impartir conocimiento o
lograr que desarrollen destrezas cuando
en el último de sus prioridades se
encuentra el aprendizaje entonces
después de algunos golpes contra la
pared descubrí que lo bueno que yo
conocía sobre la pedagogía que enseñaba
en la capital no necesariamente era lo
mejor para ellos así que tuve que
cambiar mis estrategias para poder
lograr resultados diferentes como los
tan conocidos pedagogos jackson fire
dijeron alguna vez baby si es así as one
two three entonces me gustaría compartir
con ustedes tres pasos que nos enseña
cómo poder combatir y poder enseñar ante
esta situación el primer paso es
apreciar la diversidad
por una parte está la capitalina que
llega y por otra está un grupo de
estudiantes que la mayoría son kutcher
que no dominan muy bien el quechua no
dominan muy bien el español y llega a
ella querer enseñarles inglés entonces
al momento de poder apreciar nuestras
diferencias tuve que hacer un cambio en
nuestro currículo yo quería enseñarles
como países del mundo y grandes ciudades
de europa pero ellos ni siquiera conocen
la capital de su país entonces tenía que
ajustar el conocimiento que ellos
necesitaban empezamos a hablar sobre
conocimiento de lugares aledaños a ellos
su vestimenta sus tradiciones su danza
sus costumbres entonces podíamos
intercambiar conocimiento ellos me
enseñaban a mí lo suyo y yo podía
enseñarles también lo que yo conocía una
vez que ya les tenía en mis manos para
poder enseñarles bien el paso número dos
causar bienestar
no sé cuántos de ustedes tal vez han
tenido la oportunidad de visitar la
cultura quichua afectivamente
ellos carecen muchísimo especialmente en
expresiones corporales ellos no se
abrazan rara vez hay palabras de aliento
entonces para no ponerles incómodos
tuvimos que buscar otras estrategias y
descubrimos y descubrimos que darles el
patrocinio también un poco de mostrarles
interés y más que todo que ellos sean
protagonistas de eventos hacía que ellos
se sentían importantes entonces
empezamos con eventos como bailes
navideños es muy común en nuestro
entorno planear los pero en este caso
especial los profesores nos hicimos a un
lado solamente formamos comisiones y era
interesante ver como ellos
planificaban en la quema del viejo o la
decoración y el dj y la música entonces
al final cuando realizábamos una
retroalimentación ellos veían wow
todo eso pude hacer yo entonces nos
aplaudimos todos también hacíamos
eventos de deportes y juegos porque como
saben el fútbol hunde más así en nuestra
ciudad no es diferente sólo que en lugar
de hacer la final en nuestro edificio
aburrido que tenemos en la noche
gestionábamos para poder realizar en el
parque tan hermoso que presenta nuestra
ciudad y ellos se sentían importantes de
poder que la ciudad veía como jugaban
entonces se sentían que valían que
valían algo el valor que habían perdido
al principio también actividades como
paseos por la zona
ya que nosotros no podemos costear nos
un viaje a quito peor aún a galápagos
como es de tradición al final del año
tomamos como ventaja los parajes que nos
ofrecen nuestra ciudad así que empezamos
alumnos y docentes a visitar estos estos
lugares y claro ellos nos daban de largo
porque manejan muy bien estos terrenos
en la anotación en las en la escala de
la selva pero sin embargo nos sentíamos
a esa efectividad que estábamos buscando
no lográbamos a través de eventos tan
simples por último el tercer paso que no
puedo decir que lo he logrado del todo
es fomentar la independencia crear
alumnos y alumnas auto motivadas y auto
motivados a que al salir después de sus
tres años de bachillerato ellas ellos
sigan sintiendo
esa importancia que les dimos durante el
colegio sabemos que muchos salen
nadie aspira a la universidad pero ahora
está aumentando el grupo en el que por
lo menos va a institutos superiores
técnicos y eso es una gran gran aliento
para nosotros y los que no pues se
dedican a la venta de productos locales
o negocios pequeños de comidas rápida
entonces tenemos un proyecto de
seguimiento en el que cuando ofrece un
evento público nuestra ciudad les
invitamos a estos estudiantes para que
formen parte gestionamos algunos
permisos para que ellos puedan vender
sus productos y a la vez aprovechamos en
preguntarles cómo se han sentido que ha
pasado de nuevo en sus vidas después de
haber dejado el colegio y el proyecto
más grande que tenemos es
hacer una escuela para padres como les
mencioné muchos ya son desde
adolescentes madres y padres y lo que
queremos es enseñarles a que sean buenos
padres y buenas madres para que asienten
en diferente a sus hijos y se rompe este
ciclo que aprendieron de sus padres y
sus padres antes de ellos entonces
fomentar nuevas generaciones a través de
la educación que no solamente ha sido en
inglés sino que hemos abarcado
muchísimos otros aspectos ante esta
realidad que les acabo de mencionar y si
alguna vez se enfrentan algo similar si
te preguntas se cayó la canasta muy bien
entonces recojamos las frutas pero aún
más importante escuchemos las historias
que quieren decirnos los chicos y las
chicas hay que pagar h muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]